Hey guys, it's Jan here.
I absolutely loved the epic trailer for Suicide
Squad and quite frankly I cannot wait until
August rolls around and we finally get to
see the worst of the worst up there in all
their glory on the big screen!
There's been some crazy reports of what went
down on set during the movie's shoot too,
so I wanted to look at 7 of the most insane,
crazy, WTF facts so far about the Suicide
Squad movie!
According to Ike Barinholtz, who's best known
for The Mindy Project and the Neigbors movies
with Zac Efron and Seth Rogen, Suicide Squad
director David Ayer loves to really mess with
his actors' minds before they start filming,
telling them all sorts of crazy stuff to get
them into the dark place he wants them in
for their character.
Barinholtz, whose Suicide Squad character
is yet to be revealed, says that Ayer used
a similar trick on his last movie, Fury, and
it very nearly ended in a fight between Shia
LaBeouf and Jon Bernthal.
And during Cara Delevingne's audition for
Suicide Squad's Enchantress, David Ayer riled
up Delevingne so much that she says she wanted
to kill someone by the time she left!
And precisely because Ayer insisted his actors
went to all the traumatic places they needed
to go to really bring their characters to
vivid life, the director had a therapist brought
on set for the cast, according to Adam Beach,
who plays Slipknot in the movie,
Well, not exactly, a therapist, but a life
coach who's a friend of Ayer's was there to
make sure none of the cast took their psychotic
work home with them!
As for Jared Leto, who plays The Joker, he
stayed in character while filming the entire
movie, just as he did for his Oscar-winning
turn in the movie Dallas Buyers Club.
Will Smith, who plays Deadshot, said that
Leto never spoke a single word to Smith as
himself during the whole six-month shoot.
According to Suicide Squad producer Charles
Roven, Leto isolated himself from the rest
of the cast, which actually helped the Suicide
Squad gang to bond, and on top of that, Leto
wouldn't come to set unless the crew called
him Mr J.
In fact, Jared Leto has taken his method acting
to a whole new level on Suicide Squad, sending
his cast-mates a bunch of disturbing gifts.
Leto sent his co-stars who were in rehearsals
at the time a video of himself in character
telling them he was sorry not to be there
but was working just as hard as they were.
For Margot Robbie, whose Harley Quinn character
is The Joker's lover in the comic books, Leto
sent a love letter plus a box with a live
rat inside!
Will Smith also got a letter from The Joker
actor, but his one was accompanied by bullets!
And what does a method actor playing one of
DC's greatest villains get his cast-mates
as a group gift?
A dead pig, of course!
Margot Robbie really got into her crazy Harley
Quinn character setting up her own Tattoo
Parlour and inking the word Skwad on to her
co-stars' arms.
Will Smith also had a go at tattooing Joel
Kinnamon, who plays Suicide Squad leader Rick
Flagg.
However, apparently tattooing isn't one of
Smith's many talents, in fact, to quote Kinnamon,
'it was like watching a drunk baby fly a helicopter'!
But when it comes to having a blast on set,
Will Smith definitely is your man.
When an all-night shoot meant the cast and
crew missed the Manny Pacquiao-Floyd Mayweather
fight, Smith took care of business, arranging
for three cinema screens to be set up so everyone
could watch the fight the next day during
lunch and on top of that he hired a restaurant
to cater for all 500 people!
And not content with his boxing match endeavours,
Will Smith also pumped up the volume along
with the tempo and threw a party for the cast
and crew including a special concert with
none other than DJ Jazzy Jeff.
The guys performed ten songs together.
Doubtless a good bit of practice for their
2016 reunion tour!
So, guys, what are you looking forward to
most about Suicide Squad?
What kind of Joker do you think Jared Leto's
going to make?
And are there any other crazy things you're
heard about the movie and its stars?
I've got more DC and comic book videos coming
up shortly, so do subscribe for those.
And you can check out some links here for
more of my movie facts, Easter Eggs, and Comic
Con videos!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!